eu sou cantora musicista e mãe de um
garoto autista e eu vou falar sobre
autismo música porque no meu
entendimento são coisas que embora
distintas elas estão totalmente
interligadas
então eu começo apresentando pra vocês
alguns conceitos é daquilo que forma
música para que eu possa a partir daí
traçar uma analogia da música com
algumas particularidades do autismo
a música ritmo harmonia e melodia e
esses elementos dependem de uma
estrutura sólida que é a pulsação de uma
música a pulsação da música o coração
dela assim como o nosso batimento
cardíaco essa acusação também pode
variar por exemplo se você está dormindo
se está relaxado se está correndo seu
batimento cardíaco vai ser um e toda sua
estrutura física vai estar relacionada
com este batimento cardíaco
da mesma maneira a pulsação musical vai
determinar toda a estrutura de uma
música é necessário que um grupo que
toca uma música cinta de forma igual
essa pulsação para poder reproduzir lá
não dá pra cada músico sentir a pulsação
no lugar ficaria uma loucura se a gente
ouviu uma orquestra e cada um desses
orquestra tocar sentir essa acusação de
uma forma diferente buscando vai
acontecer então a partir dessa solidez
que é a pulsação a base nós chegamos ao
ritmo o ritmo são moldes de expressão
desses batimentos desse pulso cada
pessoa tem uma forma de lidar com o
ritmo
é como se cada um de nós tivesse uma
forma pessoal de lidar com determinada
informação por isso é muito comum a
gente dizer que cada pessoa tem seu
ritmo totalmente ligada a essa estrutura
rítmica
nós temos a melodia a melodia é a linha
que traz o desenho de uma música é a
primeira manifestação de comunicação que
a gente tem com os nossos ouvintes e
essa comunicação não precisa de letra
para ser compreendida
ela pode ser apenas sentida o time
elemento dessa estrutura é a harmonia
eram harmonia é o colorido sonoro que a
música tem é o terreno fértil aonde a
melodia vai se desenvolver livremente
como um poema sobre as linhas de um
caderno
aqui falamos de estruturas distintas que
interferem umas nas outras e que devem
fluir acima de tudo
falamos que cada um desses elementos têm
função específica e seu próprio grau de
importância e é a partir da combinação
desses elementos que a música acontece e
é por isso inclusive que somos capazes
de aprender uma música reproduzir e
memorizar uma música poucos de nós se
preparam para ouvir ou se preocupam em
perceber o ambiente em que uma melodia
se constrói de uma comunicação se
constrói
poucas pessoas são capazes até de
identificar os instrumentos que fazem
parte de uma música é preciso observar
isso para poder conseguir modificar isso
e é aqui que a música eo autismo começam
a conversar mais diretamente em razão da
sensibilidade precisa e apurado do
autista
a percepção do autista do mundo é como a
percepção do maestro mais exigente e
cuidadoso
diante de uma orquestra de músicos que
ele nunca viu nem ouviu tocar e de uma
sinfonia que ele não escreveu como
musicista e mãe do meu garotão que ele
já está mais do que eu
eu acredito que o excesso de estímulos
que nossos filhos recebem um sonho pra
eles como uma banda completamente
desafinada aos seus ouvidos perfeitos e
absolutos isso causa um desconforto
maior do que o desconforto emocional
causa desconforto físico e causa repúdio
ea partir daí tudo dá errado
é como se tudo se quebrasse eles ficam
totalmente desestruturadas edição diz
harmonizados
então me pergunto frequentemente como
meu filho escutar minha música como ele
escuta a minha banda ela está num ritmo
agradável harmonia da minha música
permite que a melodia do meu filho flor
essa livremente nós pais familiares
sociedade precisamos trabalhar como
compositores de uma música e maestro de
uma orquestra
cada escolha que fazemos deve ser com
uma nota musical perfeita no lugar certo
tudo deve ter função e importância ter
coerência organização e fluindo com
criatividade porque a nossa vida é
criatividade
devemos enxergar através daquilo que
queremos como resultado e não
simplesmente deixar as coisas
acontecerem para depois analisarmos o
resultado no entanto assim como a música
a vida depende de muitos elementos que
agem juntos que se incluem uns nos
outros
ou seja estruturaram estruturar um
ambiente não é isolar esse ambiente do
mundo de fórmula 1
a vida não é isolada a vida em conjunto
e isso é inclusão inclusão familiar é
nossa pulsação nosso ritmo
a primeira fonte de estrutura a base das
nossas vidas
ela precisa acontecer a gente sabe no
dia a dia que eu vou dar um exemplo
muito prático aqui a gente tem aquela
situação que a gente chega numa reunião
familiar com os nossos filhos autistas e
muitos são muito agitados ou são mais
quietinhos mas na minha experiência ele
é um menino realmente agitado
isso não é um problema fica todo mundo
com aquela situação desconcertante
olhando para o lado porque ele diz estou
daquele ambiente na verdade ele não
gostou ele tem uma ele tem uma pulsação
diferenciada ele sente aqui a pulsação
daquele ambiente diferente dos outros e
é nessa hora que a gente tem que falar
olha vem você com a sua pulsação porque
eu também posso chegar até a sua ea
gente pode compartilhar do mesmo
ambiente cada situação apresenta uma
pulsação pra gente a gente faz isso no
nosso dia a dia o tempo todo a gente
anda mais rápido a gente anda mais
devagar a gente acompanha a pessoa que
está do nosso lado a gente recua porque
não dá pra passar porque a rua é
estreita
eu acho que a vida é isso
ninguém sobrevive sem essa base sem esse
coração porém podem até substituí lá
algumas pessoas não têm o apoio familiar
e não tenho ilusão familiar e elas
encontram em outro lugar mas não é
possível imaginar a vida sem ela a
inclusão educacional é nossa segunda
fonte de estrutura pois é na escola que
praticamos o conceito de sociedade todos
nós
a convivência fora do lar é nossa
melodia a forma com que vamos nos
relacionar com o mundo é como vamos
lidar com as coisas como autista vai
lidar com as pessoas e como as pessoas
vão lidar com autismo é na escola que
eles aprendem isso no convívio com a
escola são nossos filhos que vão dizer
olha eu tenho um colega que está na
escola pai ele é legal
ele está bem ele morde próprio braço ele
se machuca quando ele está nervoso
de repente ele estoura ele corre o tempo
todo
ele falou hoje eu nunca ouvi a voz dele
nós ele tira 10 e matemática
mas ele não usa agasalho quando está com
frio esses assuntos precisam acontecer
na casa das pessoas naturalmente para
que a gente chegue na inclusão social
só dessa forma que é a harmonização o
ambiente da realização concreta da
inclusão familiar e da inclusão
educacional através da inclusão familiar
e da inclusão educacional é que o
autista vai ser inserido e ser
respeitado na nossa sociedade e como
integrar inclusão social música e
autismo
como falamos a música oferece um
ambiente totalmente estruturado
totalmente convidativo e por isso nós
gostamos tanto e nos integramos tanto
com a música e saímos de nós mesmos para
poder executá lá para poder sentir lá e
por isso ela faz tanta diferença na vida
das pessoas e na vida do artista em
particular milagres há muitos têm muitas
histórias
apesar de ser um exercício e cantor em
particular minha situação pessoal meu
filho não canta comigo ele ainda não
deixa eu acho que não está afinado o
suficiente pra ele
é assim que a gente se dê conta a
estrutura musical é uma estrutura que
envolve nossas vidas
é como se vivêssemos dentro de uma
grande sintonia com o movimento os
sentimentos resultados instrumentos
variados e foi partindo desse conceito
de estrutura de movimento instrumento
que percebi que poderia prover pro meu
filho as músicas da sua vida
bom se como musicista sou capaz de
sentir música através de uma partitura
musical de me integrar com ela
completamente porque não usar esse
princípio para ajudar meu filho se
integrar com a grande sinfonia da vida
porque não ajudá lo com por sua própria
música e como fizemos isso eu aproveitei
o talento do meu marido meu marido é
desenhista e nós usamos uma estrutura de
comunicação que não sou o filho é capaz
de interpretar e criamos desenhos para
comunicar a ele o que acreditamos que
como pais
ele deve aprender demos a ele uma
ferramenta de apoio visual para que ele
seja capaz de interpretar situações e
ações como uma partitura musical
demos a ele uma estrutura com o ritmo e
harmonia
o ambiente para que ele produza a sua
própria melodia
ele vai dizer como ele vai executar eu
só mostro um caminho para ele a sua
comunicação
essa ferramenta de apoio visual são
decisivos roteirizadas de ações em
momentos que queremos que ele interprete
melhor que ele compreenda melhor
tornando se um observador da sua própria
ação para situações como banho escovar
os dentes e ir ao cinema e na escola
aceitar a ajuda da professora mostrando
um desenho roteirizado como a partitura
de uma música para o instrumentista e
dizemos a ele pode tocar e ele faz o seu
próprio som e com sua própria melodia e
durante o dia várias músicas são em
toadas vários desenhos são vistos até
que isso fique decorado entendido se
torne parte da vida dele
assim como uma música que ouvimos várias
vezes que gostamos e aprendemos a cantar
esses desenhos essas experiências
positivas nos ajudam e se nos ajudam
tanto porque não compartilhar com os
outros
então a partir desse pensamento
decidimos disponibilizar todo esse
material que fizemos para o nosso filho
e que fazemos no dia a dia através de um
site
é um material feito por pais e para o
país
criamos o site autismo projeto integrar
onde produzimos essas ferramentas de
apoio visual
essas partituras para gerar capacidade
aos nossos filhos porque acreditamos que
o apoio gera capacidade
façamos nossos filhos capazes devemos
acreditar todos os dias que mesmo em
nossos maiores desafios nós podemos fazê
los capaz
sejamos os compositores de nossas ações
e os maestros de nossa vida pública